Si hay un país en el mundo con razones para
tener pánico a la energía nuclear, ese es
JAPÓN. Habéis oído bien, los japoneses
tienen un historial nuclear cuanto menos traumático.
Pensadlo bien, Japón es, por ahora, el único
país que ha sufrido un ataque nuclear: los
bombardeos de HIROSHIMA y NAGASAKI. Durante
los años 50, los japoneses tenían auténtico
pánico nuclear. Prueba de ello son películas
tan míticas como Godzilla: un lagarto radioactivo
que destruye ciudades. Sin embargo, a medida
que el país crecía, necesitaba más energía.
En los años 60, Japón construyó sus primeros
reactores nucleares. Y un par de décadas
después, el país del Sol Naciente se convirtió
la tercera potencia nuclear del mundo, sólo
por detrás de Estados Unidos y Francia. Habéis
oído bien. Mientras en España se organizaban
manifestaciones antinucleares, Japón confiaba
ciegamente en el uranio. Y entonces, cuando
todos parecían estar encantados con los reactores
y los átomos, ocurrió lo inimaginable.
El terremoto en Japón provoca una explosión
en la central nuclear de Fukushima
Una poderosa explosión golpea una central
nuclear en el Noreste de Japón, que es una
de las regiones más afectadas por el devastador
terremoto y el tsunami.
De la noche a la mañana, el pánico nuclear
volvió a Japón… y al mundo entero. Cuando
ocurrió el accidente de Chernobyl en 1986,
mucha gente decía “el problema no es la
energía nuclear perse, sino el hecho de que
en Chernobyl se pasaron los protocolos de
seguridad por donde yo te diga… ¿Qué esperábais?
¡Era la Unión Soviética!” Sin embargo,
Fukushima era un caso muy distinto. Japón
cumple todos los protocolos de seguridad pero
no pudieron evitar el desastre.
De repente, este país paralizó casi todas
sus centrales. Pasaron de consumir un 30%
de nuclear a menos de un 3%. Todo apuntaba
a que Japón se sumaba al carro de los antinucleares…
¿O tal vez no?
Entre un 20 y un 22% de peso de la energía
nuclear, elemento clave de la política energética
actualizada
¡Exacto! ¡La energía nuclear vuelve a Japón!
¡Y no sólo a Japón! En realidad, podríamos
decir que todo Asia vive ahora mismo una auténtica
revolución atómica. Desde países ricos
como Japón hasta países pobres como Bangladesh.
Y esto es sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta
que los reactores nucleares son de todo menos
baratos.
En este otro vídeo os contábamos lo que
está ocurriendo en China, pero hoy vamos
a hablar de lo que está ocurriendo en los
demás países. Y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando ¿Por qué? ¿Qué tiene la energía
nuclear?¿Cómo es posible que un país pobre
pueda acceder a una tecnología tan cara como
la nuclear? Hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
VUELTA AL GIGANTE NUCLEAR
Fukushima supuso para Japón el apagón nuclear
inmediato. Los japoneses optaron por ser cautos
y desconectaron todos sus reactores. Así
que ahora os estaréis preguntando. ¿Cómo
se las apañaron sin nuclear de un día para
otro? Pues con un auténtico harakiri ecologista
¡Habéis oído bien! Si pensabais que la
energía nuclear no es ecológica, muchas
de las alternativas son aún peores…
A falta de Uranio, Japón recurrió a la importación
de combustibles fósiles y eso tuvo dos consecuencias:
Por un lado, aumentó un 20% el precio de la electricidad,
pero también aumentaron considerablemente las
emisiones de CO2. Vamos, que si Godzilla aparece
en Fukushima, más le vale ponerse una mascarilla.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¿Por qué
no utilizan energías renovables? Lo cierto
es que instalar renovables requiere mucho
tiempo. Y en un país como Japón, donde están
obsesionados con la competitividad, llevan
años de retraso con las renovables.
AHORA,
han empezado un nuevo plan energético y el
objetivo es llegar a un 22% de consumo de
renovables… ¡Para 2030! Para que os hagáis
una idea, en Europa se llegará a este objetivo
en 2020 ¿Por qué? Pues, básicamente, porque
en Europa se empezó a invertir en renovables
mucho antes.
Lo cierto es que la energía renovable es
mucho más compleja de lo que parece. Y hace
falta mucho mas que buena voluntad. En los
últimos 8 años, Japón ha multiplicado por
10 su potencia solar. Pero, por ejemplo, los
datos de la eólica todavía son muy pobres:
aporta sólo un 0,5% de la electricidad.
Uno
de los problemas que tiene es la burocracia.
Si queréis poner en marcha un parque eólico
en Japón, necesitáis más de 5 años de
papeles y permisos. Eso es más del triple
de lo habitual en otros países. Es decir,
que no sólo es un problema técnico sino
también legal. Y reducir la burocracia es
complicado en todos los países.
Por otra parte, la energía solar o la eólica
dependen del tiempo que hace. Si se levanta
un día con poco sol o poco viento, apenas
hay energía. Y, por el momento, no hay muchos
sistemas para almacenar energía de forma
viable.
En otras palabras, que Japón tiene dos opciones:
o importar combustibles fósiles, lo que es
caro y contamina una barbaridad… ¡O volver
a la nuclear!
Japón reinicia 5 reactores nucleares en 2018
5 reactores en 2018 que se suman a los 4 que
habían vuelto a funcionar previamente. ¡Pero
no sólo han reactivado los reactores que
ya tenían! ¡Además, quieren construir más!
Comienza el proceso para operar un nuevo reactor
en la central nuclear de Shimane
Veréis, cuando hablamos de energía nuclear,
hay una cosa muy importante que tenemos que
entender: producen energía de forma continuada.
Es decir: desde el momento en el que ponemos
a funcionar un reactor, todos los días produce
la misma cantidad de energía. Ni más ni
menos. Y por eso decimos que las centrales
nucleares son centrales de carga de base.
Las centrales de carga de base no tienen flexibilidad
para arrancar o cesar su producción de energía
según las necesidades. Apagar una central
nuclear es muy caro y sólo se puede hacer
en casos de riesgo de accidente. Por eso,
la central nuclear es la base de un sistema
eléctrico. Sobre eso, podemos sumar otras
fuentes alternativas como las renovables,
las centrales de carbón, etc… cuya producción
se puede ajustar dependiendo de la demanda.
Sin embargo, si decíamos que las renovables
dependen del tiempo que hace, las centrales
de gas o de carbón dependen de los precios
de mercado, que cambian cada día. Sin embargo,
la nuclear nos da electricidad a un coste
mucho más previsible. Y por eso es una fuente
de energía tan interesante.
Algo similar pasa en Corea del Sur.
Mientras sus vecinos del Norte construían bombas,
Seúl se dedicó a desarrollar una industria
nuclear muy parecida a la de Japón. Tienen
4 centrales nucleares con 6 reactores cada
una.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién construye las
centrales nucleares? Pues lo cierto es que
la tecnología nuclear es complicadísima
y hay muy pocas empresas en este sector ¿Os
acordáis de esos reactores que instaló Japón
en los 60? Pues estaban construidos por empresas
británicas y
estadounidenses. Durante años, General Electric
y Westinghouse dominaban el mercado.
Pero en seguida llegaron TOSHIBA, HITACHI y MITSUBISHI con sus propios diseños.
En Corea del Sur pasó algo parecido. Empezaron
comprando a Estados Unidos, Francia y Canadá…
Pero, con el tiempo, empresas surcoreanas
como HYUNDAY, DOOSAN o KEPCO terminaron fabricando
sus propios reactores. Y ahora, Corea del
Sur es toda una potencia nuclear que vende
en todo el mundo.
Emiratos Árabes Unidos y Corea del Sur celebran
la finalización del primer reactor nuclear
de Barakah
Y ahora os preguntaréis: vale pero… ¿Cuánto
cuesta un reactor nuclear? Pues, por ejemplo,
todos los reactores que van a instalar en
la Península Arábiga cuestan alrededor de
20.000 millones de dólares. Por compararlo,
una planta tde combustibles fósiles que genere
la misma cantidad de energía puede costar
hasta 20 veces menos. Por supuesto, una vez
construidos, producir un kilowatio de nuclear
es muy barato. Pero a ver quién es el guapo
al que le sobran 20.000 millones de dólares
para montar una central nuclear. Entonces
¿Cómo es posible que países relativamente
pobres como la India o Bangladesh puedan construir
reactores nucleares? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
DE GODZILLA A GOGOLA
Si Japón tiene a Godzilla, la India tiene
a Gogola.
Por si no lo sabíais, tras el éxito
de Godzilla en los años 50, Bollywood sacó
su propia versión. Y ese fue nada más y
nada menos que el gigante Gogola.
¡Pero no sólo hablamos de películas! También
hablamos de energía. Si Japón tiene centrales
nucleares, la India también quiere tenerlas
¿El problema? Que las empresas estadounidenses
no pueden vender reactores a la India ¿Por
qué? Pues porque desde los años 70, la India
tiene bombas atómicas ¡Tal cual como lo
oís! El país de Gandhi y la no violencia
es una de las potencias que tiene armamento
nuclear. Y vista su enemistad manifiesta con
Pakistán, no sería descabellado pensar que
algún día quisieran usarlo.
En otras palabras, que a Estados Unidos no
le interesa ayudar a que India se nuclearice
aún más.
¡Pero hay algo aún más interesante! Veréis,
a diferencia de Japón o Corea del Sur, la
India sí tiene sus propias minas de Uranio.
Y como Estados Unidos les dio la espalda,
se fueron a Rusia y Francia. Muchas de los
de los reactores indios están construidos
por empresas rusas como ROSATOM ¡No sólo
eso! Los reactores de la India tienen algo
muy particular: son mucho más baratos que
en ningún otro lugar ¿Por qué? Pues porque
son las únicas que utilizan uranio natural.
Veréis, casi todos los reactores nucleares
del mundo utilizan el llamado URANIO ENRIQUECIDO.
Este tipo de uranio se puede usar para producir
energía pero no para hacer bombas. Por eso,
todos los países pueden comprar uranio enriquecido
sin problemas.
Ahora bien, si tú quieres comprar uranio
natural, te van a decir: “chst! Eh! ¿Dónde
vas tu con eso? ¿Qué pasa, que quieres fabricar
bombas atómicas?
¡Anda! ¡Anda!
¡Deja eso en la estantería, desgraciado!
¡Y vete para tu casa!”
Sin embargo, como la India tiene su propio
uranio, puede hacer lo que quiera con él.
Y eso significa que sus reactores usan uranio
natural y, por tanto, son más baratos. Y
eso explica noticias como esta.
La India planea multiplicar por 10 su producción
de uranio
Actualmente la India está construyendo 7
reactores nucleares pero en sus planes figura
desarrollar 20 más. Como os decía antes,
una de las empresas que más reactores construye
en la India es la rusa ROSATOM. Y ya que están
por esa zona, también se han ido a hacer
negocios a los países vecinos.
Rosatom comienza a trabajar en la segunda
unidad del proyecto nuclear de Bangladesh
Con esto, Bangladesh va a poder cubrir el
20% de su demanda eléctrica con nuclear.
Y algo parecido está pasando en Pakistán.
En este caso, los pakistaníes van a ser los
primeros en comprar reactores made in China.
En otras palabras, que la nuclear ya no es
cosa de ricos. Y en Asia están como locos
por tener reactores.
Por último, atentos a esto, porque la nuclear
está a punto de dejar de ser cosa de ricos.
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Qué pasará
finalmente con las centrales nucleares de
Japón que permanecen en suspenso? ¿Creéis
que los planes de la India, Pakistán o Bangladesh
puede propiciar un despertar nuclear en economías
en desarrollo?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os
ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y has pronto.